Voiceover: What I want
to do with this video
is explore the idea of allele frequency.
Allele frequency.
Just as a reminder, an allele
is a variant of a gene.
You get a variant of a
gene from your mother,
and you get another variant of the gene
from the father.
So, when we're talking about
the allele, we're talking
about that specific
variant that you got from
your mother or your father.
We've seen this before, but now let's dig
a little bit deeper.
To help us get our heads
around this, we'll start
with a fairly common model for this.
We're going to think about eye color.
Obviously, this is a very
large simplification, but
let's just assume that we
have a population where
there's only two variants
of an eye color gene.
Let's first assume there
is an eye color gene.
Let's assume there's two variants.
One variant, one allele for
eye color, we'll use the
shorthand, capital B.
Let's say that's the allele for brown.
Brown eye color.
We're going to assume
that this one is dominant.
It's dominant over the other allele.
Now the other allele, we're
going to assume is for
blue eye color, and we'll
represent that with a
lower case B.
So that is blue eye color,
and we're going to assume
that this is recessive.
Once again, this is review.
Someone who has one of
the big B alleles, the
brown alleles, it doesn't
matter what their other
allele is going to be, because
it's either going to be
another brown or it's
going to be a blue, they're
going to show brown eyes.
This is going to be brown
eyes, and this is going
to be brown eyes, because the capital B is
dominant.
The only way to get blue
eyes is to be a homozygote
for the recessive allele.
All of that, of course, is review.
We've seen that before.
Now let's think about allele frequency.
To think about that, I'll
set up a very artificially
small population.
Let's say our population has
exactly two people in it.
Population has exactly
two people in it, Person 1
and Person 2, and let's
say we're able to look
into their DNA and figure
out their genotypes.
Person 1, say, has a capital
B allele, has a brown
allele and a blue allele,
while Person 2 has two
blue, two blue alleles.
Given that we know the
genotypes in this artificially
small population, we
could start thinking about
the allele frequencies.
Or the frequencies of
the different alleles.
What do you think is
going to be the frequency
the frequency of the brown
allele in this population?
I encourage you to pause
this video and think
about this on your own.
I'm assuming you've had a
go at it, so you might be
tempted to say, "Looks
like one out of two people
"have it, maybe it's 50%."
But that wouldn't be the
right way to think about
allele frequencies.
In allele frequencies, you
want to dig a little bit
deeper and look at the individual alleles.
When you look at that,
you say, "Okay, there's
"four individual alleles in
this population, or there's
"four variants, or there's
literally four chromosomes
"that are carrying that
gene in this population."
Out of them, one of them
carry, one of them is the
capital B allele, so we could
say that that is going to
be zero point two five, or 25%.
Once again, 25% of the
genes for eye color have the
capital B allele, have the brown allele.
Now we can do the same,
ask ourselves the same
question for the lower case B allele.
What fraction of the genes
in this population are
code for or represent
the lower case B, the
blue allele?
Once again, I encourage
you to pause the video
and think about it.
Well, very similar idea.
There's four genes in
the population that are
coding for eye color.
Of them, one, two, three
code for or are the lower
case blue allele.
So that's zero point seven five or 75%.
75% of the genes code for
the lower case blue allele,
while 25 are the brown allele.
I really want to hit this
point home, how this is
different than, say,
the phenotype frequency.
If I asked you, in the
population, if I asked you the
percent of brown-eyed
people, so now I'm talking
about phenotype, what would that be?
Well, there's two people
in the population.
One of them is exhibiting
brown eyes, so that's
going to be one-half.
Similarly, if I were to ask
you what is the percentage
of people who are
blue-eyed that, too, would
be one-half.
This person is one of
the two people, they're
exhibiting blue eyes.
But allele frequency,
we're digging deeper, we're
looking at the genotypes.
We're saying out of the
four genes here, one of
them is the big B allele,
so that's 25% of the gene
population codes for the brown allele and
75% is the blue allele.
This is really important to internalize.
Because once we internalize
this, then as we'll see,
that the ideas in the
Hardy-Weinberg principle
start to make a lot of sense.
I'll do a little bit of foreshadowing.
We can denote this, this
is just a convention that's
often used, by the lower
case letter P, and we can
use lower case Q to denote the frequency.
So lower case P is the
frequency of the dominant
allele, lower case Q the frequency of the
recessive allele.
What's true here?
What's true of P, what's
going to be true of
P plus Q, what's P plus
Q going to be equal to?
I encourage you to pause the video again
and think about that.
What is this going to be equal to?
Well, when we started
off, we said that there's
only two potential, that's
one of the assumptions
we assumed, we assumed
there's only two alleles
in this population, in kind of the allele
population for this gene
population for this trait.
The frequency of the
dominant ones plus the
frequency of recessive
ones, well everyone's going
to have one of those two,
so if you add those two
frequencies, it's going
to have to add to 100%.
We see that there.
One-fourth plus three-fourths
is one, or 100%.
And 25% plus 75% is also 100%.
So we could say P plus Q
is equal to 100%, or we
could say that P plus Q is equal to one.
Is equal to one.
So, in the next video, we're
going to start from the
seemingly fairly simple
idea, to get to a more richer
and fairly neat idea
that's expressed in the
Hardy-Weinberg equation.